bonjour à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver en direct sur figaro live et
sur youtube également aujourd'hui lundi
5 juillet 2021 en cette veille de
vacances d'été en cette veille de moment
où beaucoup d'entre vous vont prendre
leurs congés estivaux en france ou
ailleurs et bien vous vous posez
certainement des questions sur le co
vide 19 et son impact sur votre été que
disent les derniers chiffres le variant
d'el tabakh t-il gâcher votre été
faut-il craindre une nouvelle vague de
contaminations à la rentrée la
vaccination sera t-elle obligatoire et
bien on va vous répondre on va répondre
à toutes ces questions ensemble et en
direct lors de cette émission spéciale
consacrée aux copies de 19
avant les vacances d'été et pour nous
répondre sur ce sujet et obtenir une
expertise de qualité et bien nous avons
plaisir d'être avec tristan vais
journaliste scientifique au figaro et
chef adjoint du service sciences et
médecine au figaro bonjour tristan
vais-je c'est toujours un plaisir de
vous avoir en direct sur le plateau et
pourra bénéficier de votre expertise
d'abord je voudrais vous faire réagir
tristan aux derniers propos du ministre
de la santé olivier ferrand qui a dit
dimanche en tirant la sonnette d'alarmé
depuis cinq jours le virus ne baissent
plus il erré augmente à cause du variant
delta qui est très contagieux l'exemple
anglais montrent qu'une vague est
possible d'ici la fin juillet nous
pouvons la limité et en limiter l'impact
sanitaire grâce aux gestes barrières
vaccin testé alerté protéger tristan
vais y at il des raisons de s'alarmer où
il ya des raisons d'avoir peur le
variant delta a déjà commencé à
s'imposer dans pas mal de département
les longs notamment où ils seraient
présents
au delà de 50 % des adultes ya 80% ça
dépend un peu moins qu'on pourra revenir
sur comment mesure sa présence il ya
d'autres départements la somme et loir
et cher à paris la 40%
encore une fois je vous expliquerai
selon la méthode de calcul fait pas
forcément dire qu'il ya 40% devant delta
mais ça donne une idée quoi le vaillant
simple pause s'impose assez rapidement
il est plus contagieux et on voit les co
qui recommencent à repartir à la hausse
à l'essence de reprise de l'épidémie qui
est en train de s'amorcer
oui une petite reprise de l'épidémie
alors pour l'instant elle est mesurée on
est sur un plateau on était sur un
plateau bas et le redémarrage est
relativement lent mais on a l'exemple de
l'année dernière on sait que ce type de
redémarrage relativement et une grande
inertie en fait donc une fois que sarah
ça repart si on prend pas de mesures il
ya pas de raison pour que ça s'arrête de
soi même en plus on s'y prend tôt plus
on a de chance de pouvoir limiter cette
entreprise après un épidémiologiste et
toujours très dur de savoir à quoi
imputer une reprise
est ce que par exemple lancement le
facteur météo depuis quelques semaines
joue peu sûre vu que dans les lands à
replier qu'il fait plutôt chaud là bas
ils sont que ce soit vraiment imputable
aux variants il ya une forme de 2,2 de
lever de lever des gestes-barrières
voilà on assure le rythme de cette
reprise ne va plaindre dans un premier
temps qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
endiguer ces premiers
effet là d'une reprise de l'épidémie
est-ce qu'il n'est pas déjà trop tard
vous parlez d'une inertie importante
normand il est il est jamais trop tard
en fait quand j'étais inertie importante
c'est l'inertie qu'on ne fait rien ça
que si on ne fait rien et constate qu'on
espère que les choses vont s'arrêter
d'elle-même
ça ne se produit pas voilà l'épidémie à
une inertie cancan une dynamique
s'enclenche
elle est inéluctable dans la mesure où
on ne prend pas de mesure si on met en
place rapidement des mesures il ya
toutes les raisons pour penser qu'on
pourra les stopper vers l'ailé
confinement ont été un très bon exemple
quand on a confiné
on l'a fait souvent un peu trop tard
mais quand on l'a fait c'était très
efficace c'est un essai plus tôt on
aurait pu garder confinement plus
moellons voilà c'est ça qu'il faut avoir
entendu je sais pas qui ils font venir
un confinement mais on peut voir je
pense autour de nous qui est une
certaine forme de relâchement qui est
bien compréhensible on était à un niveau
très belle d'épidémie les gens voulaient
retrouver de leur vie un peu d'avant les
restaurants ouverts cette année
culturelle ça c'est accompagné je pense
d'un relâchement dans le port du masque
en intérieur moi je vois les gens autour
de moi bah là se font la bise très
volontiers quand ils sont dans la sphère
privée
on va dire que c'est presque légitime
puisqu'on avait le sentiment que
l'épidémie était sous contrôle
un peu avec le même état d'esprit que
l'an dernier à la même époque
on s'était dit que l'épidémie était un
peu derrière oui mais sauf que l'été
dernier on a pensé qu'il était derrière
nous et puis elle est repartie pour
confiner dans ce n'est deux fois fin il
faudrait qu'on se serve de cette leçon
là on a on a cru à tort que les pieds
cette étape terminée mais je pense qu'il
ya une forme de déconfinement était
beaucoup plus progressif l'année
dernière notamment parce que je pense
qu'on était plus marqué
psychologiquement et donc le relâchement
a été plus lente
on s'était vraiment au courant du mois
de juillet font du mois de juillet que
les gens se sont vraiment relâché là
j'ai le sentiment après c'est un
sentiment chacun chacun pourra avoir une
heure pressenti fonction du lieu dans
lequel il vit mais bon à paris dans un
milieu très urbain qui donc très propice
à l'épidémie je vois dans la rue qui a
vraiment un relâchement important je dis
encore une fois il n'ya pas forcément
des choses très importantes à faire à
mes porter le masque de manière
scrupuleuse
à l'intérieur ça les gens le font encore
les transports les gens le font encore
depuis le 17 juin dernier on le rappelle
le port du masque en extérieur n'est
plus obligatoire
selon vous il faut le maintenant en
extérieur en exercice est pas nécessaire
mais est-ce que j'ai c'est que du coup
et jean associé le nom le nom de port du
masque l'extérieur on peut se faire la
bise et c est en fait en prenant la bise
on se rend pas compte mais on
démultiplie très grandement le risque de
s'infecter donc ça peut être un geste
simple ne pas se faire la bise ne pas se
serrer la main
continuer à faire des check cc des
mesures très simples qui peuvent avoir
une influence
la vaccination a elle aussi eu une
influence elle en a déjà probablement
une on le voit en angleterre en grande
bretagne les contaminations sont
repartis à la hausse manière assez
importante
les hospitalisations pas trop les morts
non plus ça c'est un motif d'espoir
alors le taux de vaccination est quand
même plus important en grande bretagne
quand même qu'on repense à propos de
chiffres par rapport à ce que vous dites
tristan on appris à quelques jours que
50% de la population française a reçu au
moins une dose de vaccin contre le coc
vite 19 33 % ont reçu deux doses selon
les derniers chiffres du ministère de la
santé du ministère de santé publique
france ce n'est pas suffisant ces
chiffres-là de vaccination en france
pour pour contrer une possible reprise
quand on entend le rond alarmiste
d'olivier ferrand à ce sujet suffira pas
à ça ça suffira pas à contenir une vague
juste parallaxe nation d'autant que la
vaccination à une forme d'inertie et
même si on commence à vacciner un peu
plus rapidement alors on y reviendra
mais il ya des preuves de doses qui font
qu'on pourrait pas vacciner beaucoup
plus rapidement c'est un peu l'idée vous
avez deux façons
le réservoir de volontaires se tarit
aussi donc l'un dans l'autre on
descendra pas sur une ligne de crête une
baisse des personnes qui dément vont se
faire vacciner une baisse des premières
injections
il ya aussi un peu plus de semble que le
remplissage des décrets d'accès nation
soit moins rapide ce qui montre qu'il ya
une alors cessé des paramètres qui sont
mal mesuré
aujourd'hui ils essayent de mesurer avec
dr livres etc le la rapidité à laquelle
les chronos remplissent possible juge
est justement de là la défiance des
populations
en fait on se situe à un niveau pour le
vaccin de pfizer on est très proches
quand même des stocks
des stocks qu'on a tant qu'on a pas non
plus de marge on n'a pas de 10 millions
dont étendu les stocks par les tenants
du cirque on a comme c'est des
livraisons par semaine assez importante
de 2 3 millions forcément au nom on a
les livraisons d'être moins rose mais
après en sept jours en les consomment
juste avant que de recevoir la cvthèque
les prises de rendez-vous actuelle à
l'instrument se parlent elles sont
suffisantes pour l'instant pour garder
une vaccination à un rythme qui permet
aux gens d'être vaccinées au moment où
il souhaite l'être pour l'instant et on
accélère trop fort on risque d'être à
cours de vaccins
oui c'est vrai que soit le cas lorsque
les seuls marche qu on s assoit les
vaccins janssen vaccin janssen et
vaccins astrazeneca pour le astrazeneca
ou grosso modo il ya que des deuxième
dose qui sont délivrés aujourd'hui plus
personne ne veut prendre de première
dose or il est des gens qui sont
éligibles un chez les plus de cinq ans
il reste près on va dire 15% de la
population avec céline mais qui pourrait
avoir recours à ces doses méline un tel
rejet de ce vaccin qu'elles seront
probablement pas utilisé pour des
premières doses avec eux pour des
deuxième dose sur le kaiser les la marge
de manoeuvre est beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus étroite
la crainte qu'il eut un moment c'est que
le la baisse d'appétence pour le vaccin
ne permettent pas de et la faveur de
l'été avec les vacances qu'on n'arrive
pas à continuer à écouler de ce qu'on
recevait on en reçoit un peu moins
pendant l'été ça va être un peu anticipé
le fait qu'il puisse y avoir une baisse
en clients un peu moins de dos cet été
qui a pu en avoir en mai ou en juin
il ya quand même des niveaux assez
soutenue de livraison ce qu'il faut
c'est être capable de toutes les données
mais c'est pas ça qui sera le levier
pour contrer la vague une vague estivale
voire même une vague en septembre il
faudra forcer s'accompagne aussi de me
de mesures de gestes barrières et si on
ne veut pas et personne le souhaite je
pense refermer des écoles vont fermer le
restaurant refermer dans les cinémas ou
les théâtres
je pense y ait encore une commande il ya
encore une chemin de crête qu'on peut
qu'on peut suivre mais ça passe par
chance un comportement plus exemplaire à
titre
individuels et bien justement les les
internautes qui nous regarde en ce
moment et qui ont prévu de passer leurs
vacances et on le comprend avec à
l'esprit l'idée que l'épidémie était
sous contrôle que doivent-ils faire
quelques elle quel mode de vie on va
dire doivent-ils adopter pendant leurs
vacances au bord de la mer où on est à
l'air libre il fait chaud on en vit
effectivement de se rassembler avec ses
amis sa famille est-ce qu'il faut porter
le masque
effectivement quand on va dans un bar
est ce qu'il faut porter le masque quand
on est collé serré sur la plage
qu'est ce qu'ils doivent faire en fait
pour limiter la propagation du virus
pendant pendant l'été encore une fois je
pense des choses simples de ne pas se
faire la bise ne pas se serrer la main
continue à mettre du gel hydroalcoolique
sont des bonnes mesures
éviter les rassemblements à l'intérieur
voilà l empêche de voir sa famille même
de faire des repas de famille venue
voulait faire en extérieur c'est des
mesures simples et évite évidemment
ventilation des espaces intérieurs est
important toujours on analyse de
l'aérosol le phénomène d'aérosols
toujours aussi important de papa je
pense qu'on est russe et il est
relativement plus facile à mettre en
application un air assez naturel un peu
plus naturellement
mais dans les espaces climatisés
vacances je pense que c'est quelque
chose soit ils sont correctement
climatisée avec une bonne circulation et
du coup ça favorise la diffusion du
virus mais aéré en ouvrant les fenêtres
est toujours une bonne une bonne
solution à la plage je pense pas qu'il
fallait porter nécessairement le laps
masque à la plage mais prendre un peu de
repos du savoir-vivre prendre quelques
mètres d'écart entre avec vos vous
convient sur la plage je pense pas que
ce soit très dérangeant et voilà encore
une fois évité éviter de se faire la
bise de d'être en contact extrêmement
rapprochés parce qu on démultiplie
les risques et après bien se faire
vacciner si on peut évidemment les
questions qu'on puisse se faire vacciner
sur son lieu de vacances on n'est plus
obligé je crois d'être vacciné sur son
lieu de première injection que les gens
qui ont été qui ont bénéficié d'une
première injection de vaccin par exemple
sur le lieu de vie leur lieu
d'habitation peuvent se faire
abstraction à vrai dire c'est une
obligation de l'interdiction qui a
toujours qui m'a toujours paru un peu
étonnante et un peu théorique parce que
en pratique vous annulez votre deuxième
rendez vous et vous en prenez un
deuxième un autre
voilà personne essayer absolument rien
qui vous empêche aujourd'hui de prendre
un vaccin ou vous en avez envie quand
vous invite c'est une première une
deuxième dose cette règle qui a été
imposée à moi m'a paru un petit peu
étonnante en termes de communication
alors je comprends le lit des mines et
c'était quoi
c'était une idée de gestion des stocks
et de mieux planifier les endroits il
fallait envoyer les doses et on aurait
des deuxième dose à faire et c'est ça
c'est très bien mais la vérité c'est que
les gens quand ils sont vaccinés dans un
centre généralement c'est celui qui est
le plus pratique pour eux dont le plus
proche de leur donner des aliments
dernier de série weeds s'ils vont le
faire dans un autre endroit c'est pas
c'est vraiment parce que pour eux c'est
beaucoup plus pratique plus simple et
donc ils ont une raison de le faire et
on peut s'imaginer que il va tout ça va
s en moyenné que ça va pas créer qui à
part sans pour enfin je passe de dix
mille personnes vaccinées au stade de
france et puis après un mois plus tard
une horde plus que mille tradition là
j'y crois pas une seule seconde que j'ai
toujours et c'est un peu étonnant et
surtout que ça ça pouvait freiner un peu
la vérité des gens alors il ya toute une
période en fait on commet manqué d'un
peu de doses
on n'a pas été très regardant sur le sur
le ce paramètre là
or c'était pas mal peut-être de garder
un peu les gens de conserver en fait
l'appétence du vaccin l'idée que c'était
quelque chose de rare de difficile à
obtenir et tout ça ça ça va le motiver
les gens aujourd'hui on
il semble que alors ça c'est bon c'est
ministère qui dit qu'il dise à de
terribles confirmé que les rendez vous
pour la première de the air de repartir
un peu à la hausse
donc c'est une bonne nouvelle c'est dire
que les gens ont conscience que
d'épidémie repart mais la vaccination
sera pas le seul
le seul remède d'autant que je rappelle
sa gelée beaucoup vu au début notamment
mai juin des gens voient la lise avancer
la bise je suis vacciné oui justement et
déjà demandé est ce que quand on est
vaccinés a finalement on peut relâcher
totalement ses efforts non non non il
faut pas relâcher tellement ses efforts
notamment les gens disaient je suis
vacciné à prévoir une dose est
aujourd'hui sain dit vraiment avoir
l'esprit le vaillant delta le gros
problème
un des gros problème qui se pose c'est
que l'efficacité après la première dose
est relativement faible ce qui était
moins le cas avec le vaccin avec le
variant anglais pour lequel on avait une
bonne efficacité deux semaines après la
première injection qui été optimale
une semaine après la deuxième pour le
variant indien c'est moins le cas là là
l'efficacité après la première dose
tombe entre eux on va y arriver d'autres
30% et elle monte à 90 % une à deux
semaines après la deuxième injection où
l'on commençait bien protégés encore une
fois c'est pas une raison pour parce
qu'on fait une fois une fois qu'on a une
ode aux nos deux doses de vaccin et que
c'est le temps d'attentes
on va dire la période de latence au
cours de laquelle il faut optimiser au
maximum les les effets du vaccin est ce
que ça veut dire que derrière on doit
faire autant attention que les personnes
non vaccinées ou on peut quand même se
permettre un certain relâchement je sais
pas comment il faut présenter les choses
je pense pas qu'on puisse se mettre à
terre la chance à offre une certaine
liberté parce qu'on a un pass sanitaires
automatiques sans avoir à refaire de
test on peut voyager donc du coup plus
facilement
je pense que c'est plutôt une bonne
chose voilà c'est le vaccin confère
qu'incertain certains avantages en
revanche sur le respect des
gestes-barrières non il faut pas que ça
ça que ça que ça que ça motive à arrêter
de porter son masque pour les amateurs
de la maladie en n'ayant rien donné
bien sûr on peut jouer directement
malien on a moins de chances de risque
de faire de forme grave
on a beaucoup moins de chance nous
transmettre vers eux mettant dix fois
moins de risque de transmettre la
maladie
ce qui est important mais il reste voilà
à titre individuel si vous voulez vous
pouvez vous sentir détendue où vous avez
quand même très peu de chances d'être
hospitalisée de déterminer les formes
graves en en plus si vous êtes jeunes
donc je comprends que une journée
détente mais collectivement
vous pouvez contribuer à faire circuler
le virus et donc est-ce que c'est infect
même dans une moindre mesure mais quand
même sur ce qui existe
exactement et vous allez finir par
contaminer des personnes non vaccinées
qui ont envie de faire de former gras
alex a remplacé hôpitaux et que in fine
et vous pouvez vous dire je m'en fiche
voilà c'est dans taxi mise avec un sac
signer une entente pour eux ok j'entends
mais ça veut dire qu'à un moment les
hôpitaux vont se remplir et que c'est
les mesures de restrictions qui vont
s'imposer pour s'imposer à tout le monde
oui avoue y compris donc si vous voulez
pour vous même devenir égoïste ne pas
revivre ce qu'on a pu vivre
soyez prudents un peu prudent je dis pas
qu'il faut rester cloîtré chez soi et
pas du tout partait en vacances elle à
la plage amusez vous et voilà si la
seule contrainte c'est de pas faire la
bise à sa famille pour les protéger ça
me paraît être quelque chose de tout à
fait
vivable est envisageable alors vous
disiez sur l'origine de cette reprise ou
des signaux qui montrent qu'il y aurait
une reprise de l'épidémie en france
vous parlez du comportement des gens
peut être un certain relâchement
l'impression qu effectivement l'épidémie
est derrière nous que l'été arrivant et
le fait qu'on ait plus l'obligation de
porter le masque à l'extérieur bien
participe au fait que de fait on se
relâche un peu
est ce que le variant indien delta dont
on dit qu'il est extrêmement contagieux
partie si possible de faire oui
évidemment à propager c'est évidemment
la remontée dans les chiffres
évidemment évidemment que c'est le fin
évidemment tout laisse penser que ce
variant est à peu près on va dire 50%
plus contagieux environs faisant que
c'est quelque chose de très difficile à
mesurer
pour justement pour les raisons que nous
explique et c'est qu'en fait quand une
épidémie et repart à quoi on la tribu
est-ce qu'on attribue au relâchement des
gens est ce qu'on attribue à la météo
est ce qu'on attribue à la biologie
propre du virus est en fait comme il est
difficile de contrôler chacun de ces
paramètres ils ont ils sont mélangés et
donc du coup arriver imputé la part de
la biologie
du virus n'est pas toujours évidente il
ya un autre aspect qui vient s'ajouter à
ces cas la vaccination qui vient
s'ajouter à ça donc
la vaccination va limiter la propagation
du virus donc ça vient contrer cet effet
donc il faut prendre en fait tous ces
paramètres là en question pour arriver a
estimé
je comprends les gens qui disent enfin
40 du mal à comprendre pourquoi ce qu'on
sait pas financer plus combien de en
fait c'est pas si simple à mesurer en
laboratoire en faire des expériences
pour essayer de voir comment les
cellules infectes les unes les autres et
ccd sélection qui prennent du temps
qu'on a à ma connaissance pas encore
faite sur le variant bien qu'on a fait
sur le variant anglais méditation ça
reste de la biologie de laboratoire la
biologie en vie réelle est différente et
en fonction en fait un un virus il est
plus contagieux il ya plusieurs facteurs
qui va entrer en jeu là ce qu'on pense
pour le vario indien c'est qu'il
s'accroche entre guillemets mieux aux
cellules qui l'a plus facilité à y
pénétrer
à partir de là soit il peut infecter
plus de cellules rapidement dans
l'organisme donc du coup la charge
virale des patients est plus élevé donc
du coup ils excrète plus de virus du
coup ils sont plus contagieux soit comme
le virus s'attache facilement aux
cellules une plus petite quantité de
virus qui nous arrive permet de
contaminer les cellules mais typiquement
on ne sait pas aujourd'hui 6e entre ces
deux races la charge virale des patients
est vraiment plus avec le variant indien
ou si c'est juste l'intérieur du corps
que ça se passe où c'est au nom de la
contamination tous assez c'est assez
compliqué à mettre en oeuvre mais ce qui
paraît évident c'est que dans tous les
endroits où le variant indien s'impose
on voit ce phénomène aurait des vergers
d'épidémie donc oui on va on va vous
parler de la grande-bretagne
effectivement c'est donc ce variant
indien donc surnommé le variante delta
justement pour éviter la stigmatisation
sur l'inde donc est en train de
provoquer des rebonds épidémique dans le
dans de nombreux pays à commencer donc
effectivement par la grande bretagne est
ce qu'on va avoir le même effet en
france où sa présence progresse
il ya aussi parmi les questions qui ont
été soulevées c'est que récemment il y à
72 heures 48 heures 72 heures au royaume
uni sur les 117 personnes décédées du
variant delta qui ont été comptabilisés
il ya quelques jours 50 étaient vaccinés
est ce qu'il faut conclure on parlait de
vaccination que la vaccination ne sert à
rien non il faut en conclure que les
gars les britanniques sont très axés des
sarts expliquez vous ce paradoxe gens
s'interrogent on dit que le variant fait
des dégâts et que les gens les pays où
le variant fait le plus de dégâts et que
l'épidémie repart c'est des pays ou qui
ont été largement vacciner alors que se
passe-t-il
mais en fait il faut voir que le vaccin
s'il est très efficace n'est pas
efficace à 100 % il est efficace à 90%
je vais prendre un car si vous avez 90 %
de votre population qui est vacciné mais
l'efficacité et de 90% vous allez au
final avoir après le même terrain pour
le voeu pour que le feu ne se propage
entre les vacciner nous vacciner c'est
même un peu plus important que ça mais
donc du coup on voit bien que finalement
plus il ya de gens vaccinés plus
finalement on va voir une proportion de
gens vaccinés non protégés qui est
importante parce que c'est mathématique
un ex voilà 10% d'une très grande
population
ça fait du monde ça fait du monde et du
coup c'est ça qui explique que le le le
le taux le taux soit plus important
après il ya un autre paramètre qui
intervient qui renforce ce ça c'est que
c'est les plus âgés qui sont plus
vaccinée en france par exemple c'est 80
pour plus 80% des soins depuis 35 ans
qui sont vaccinés contre eux un passage
très faible 2
deux jeunes donc fatalement c'est une
position plus vulnérable même vacciné
thierry klein une personne à 90 ans
vaccinés avec des doses restent plus
vulnérables qu'une jeune femme de 20 ans
non vaccinés face au virus
donc c'est ça qui explique qu'on puisse
voir ces chiffres il faut les voir comme
plutôt une prime est une bonne nouvelle
ça ça montre que le vaccin est efficace
et qui se produit exactement ce qu'on
souhaite ce à quoi on sait à quoi on
s'attend alors ça me permet de partir
maintenant sur sur l'étranger puisque je
rebondis sur la question que nous pose
de thomas gens sur youtube des vacances
au portugal et plus précisément autour
de lisbonne n'est pas conseillé point
d'interrogation
je voulais juste préciser que la
question d'une fermeture ou non des
frontières pour freiner le variant delta
c'est la gîte légitimement posée elle
agite depuis plusieurs jours déjà les
pays de l'union européenne et à ce
propos en france jean-françois
delfraissy
le président du conseil scientifique a
déclaré qu'il est déjà trop tard
alors tristan quel est le conseil
donneriez vous à un autre internaute
hommage en scylla souhaitait partir à
lisbonne au portugal où ailleurs
et pour les internautes qui ont prévu de
partir à l'étranger est ce qu'il vaut
mieux éviter d'y aller avec les risques
d'une propagation supérieure ens rentrer
en france peut-être et en ramenant le
variant depuis l'étranger alors il ya
deux choses différentes
à titre individuel je dirais pas
quelqu'un qui a prévu de passer des
vacances au portugal n'y allez pas c'est
la catastrophe
vous voilà à les yeux
évidemment si vous êtes vacciné c'est
mieux c'est de la dissidente du plan de
descente 15 ans que vous n'êtes pas
vacciné que vous et au portugal je
dirais vous prenez un risque
supplémentaire par rapport à celui passé
nos vacances en france aujourd'hui oui
voilà
après vous n'êtes pas une personne à
risque vous êtes thaksin et à deux doses
bon vous prenez pas un risque énorme à
titre individuel à l'émaillage au
portugal ou en voyage en russie
c'est votre ça c'est au niveau
individuel et puis tant que c'est
autorisé finalement c'est pas aux gens
de s'auto réguler il ya des autorités
sanitaires qui sont là pour ça qu'il
soit là pour prendre ses décisions
après au niveau collectif on sait que
les voyages on s'était montré d'ailleurs
assez récent dans une nature assez
intéressantes ont montré que l'année
dernière les voyages avaient beaucoup
contribuer au redémarrage de l'épidémie
en amorçant de nombreuses chaînes de
contamination dans les pays voilà le
tourisme en gros est un vecteur de
diffusion de la diffusion de virus assez
important ça paraît assez intuitif mais
encore fight le le montrer c'est le cas
la question se pose aujourd'hui on l'a
vu avec l'euro de football de winga dans
certains pays de contamination un peu
massive typiquement voilà des événements
comme ça des matches de football avec
des gens qui vont boire dans les bars
fêter les victoires semble exclu on est
exactement dans la 10 dans la
configuration dans la configuration de
ce virus en plus on sait que les
événements de super propagation
contribuent pour une partie importante
de la diffusion du virus
pour ceux qui accuse justement l'euro de
football de des trains un vaste
d'engendrer un vaste au phénomène de
propagation du virus en ce moment en
europe
on a des éléments concrets pour juste
pour eux alors pour l'affirmer le
quantifier
notifié le kantisme me paraît difficile
mais pensez que ça puisse jouer un jeu
un rôle d'accélérateur
ça me paraît pas du tout impossible
après encore une fois au cas par cas
parce que c'est un avenant sur
progression par nature c'est un petit
peu ils ont créé les conditions pour que
ces derniers se perforer gassion soient
plus nombreux oui c'est pas parce que
l'on fasse on devrait dans un bar où il
ya beaucoup de monde que fatalement on
va déclencher un vieux continent
propagation d une part de hasard là
dedans ce qu'ils font un super
contaminée at il faut les épaules il
faut les conditions il faut quelqu'un d'
infecté que cette personne infectée en
plus c'est une charge virale importante
pour que l'on créé ce ce phénomène donc
il n'est pas du tout évident mais c'est
sûr et leur de football on a
probablement multipliés après je me
rends pas compte que c'est un trail de
deux des grands un fils de sociologie je
me rends pas compte entre le nombre de
personnes en france qui vont faire la
fête dans les bars de combien de % le
fait qu'il ait l'euro ça augmente ce
phénomène la sacem pas résisté à mesurer
pour l'instant en tout cas je pense
qu'on a rassuré où vous avez tristan
rassurer thomas gens qui nous précise
donc lui qui c'est qui ceux qui se
demandaient si des vacances au portugal
et plus précisément à lisbonne était
conseiller ou pas voulu avait répondu il
précise lui qu'il est un jeune adulte et
vacciné complètement donc dans son cas
il peut être rassuré sur son cas
personnel personnel passe après voilà
comme toujours ça ne dispense pas de
prendre des précautions
là je dis restez vigilants exactement on
rappelle en tout cas que le pass
sanitaire européen est entré en vigueur
depuis le 1er juillet dernier il l'était
déjà en france depuis le 9 juin si vous
voulez
éviter en particulier les période de
quarantaine si vous voyagez cet été il
vous sera demandé un certificat de
vaccination des tests virologiques et
puis ce fameux qr codes en bonne et due
forme évidemment si vous venez nous
rejoindre nous répondons ce matin en
direct à toutes vos questions concernant
le kobe de 19 et vos vacances d'été
avant vos vacances à voir tout ce qu'il
faut sur ce virus sa propagation le
redémarrage d'une épidémie et puis
probablement ce qui pourrait se passer à
la rentrée si on ne prête pas attention
à aux gestes barrières et qu'on est cons
et qu'on lève un peu le pied donc posé
vous posez nouveau question peut-être
nous part de vos commentaires et tristan
vrai journal scientifique au figaro vous
répond en direct
tristan avait toujours à propos de
vaccination quel est le délai idéal
entre deux doses de vaccin c'est vrai
que chaque vaccin fonctionne avec son
propre planning on va dire on est un peu
perdu
alors bon après j'ai parlé du kaiser
s'est quand même suffit avec une fin qui
contribue à constituer plus de plus des
trois quarts des vaccinations
technologies modernes
les essais cliniques ont été faits avec
un espacement des doses de six semaines
néanmoins comment il a été fait un peu
peut-être pas au hasard mais il ya une
part dans la dent là dedans la
définition d'un vaccin et la ton monta
mythologie qui repose sur du rationnel
mais qui repose aussi un peu sur de
l'intuition et c'est l'essai clinique
après valide ce protocole une fois qu'il
est validée et qui donne des résultats
qui sont satisfaisants on va pas en
changer au risque au risque de jugement
de patte de perturber ce protocole les
deux copines elles restent attendus ça
avait été fait un peu en grande bretagne
le choix d'espèces à des doses avec les
deux vaccins pour en fait l'idée c'était
de vacciner un maximum de gens la
première dose rapidement encore une fois
je lis un peu explique le début mais
c'est dans un contexte où on savait
justement grâce à ces essais cliniques
que face aux variants traditionnelle et
anglais il semblait que la protection
soit assez importante
après hambourg une dizaine de jours
après la première dose on atteignait des
niveaux de protection de l'ordre de 80 %
donc assez élevé donc le pari anglais
c'est de se dire mieux vaut vacciner
deux fois plus de gens protégé à 80% que
vacciner la moitié de ces personnes là
et protège à 95 % ce qui est un
rationnel tout à fait intéressant qui
devient complètement
complètement fou avec le variant indien
où on s'aperçoit que on n'a plus du tout
cette protection
la première dose et que c'est seulement
après deux semaines après la deuxième
dose qu'on va voir qu'on vend la
protection optimale après pour ce qui
est de l'écart maximal ça va en gros il
ya deux manières de voir les choses soit
on réduit l'espacement entre ces deux
doses
il est le risque l'heureux et pas le
moindre risque c'est juste que les
vallées les hymnes je pense que plus on
espace les doses plus la protection
conférée par le vaccin a priori a
tendance à être longue longue
en gros si vous vous écartez les deux de
12 semaines et d'être protégé par notre
vaccin pendant deux ans oui j n'importe
quoi c'est pas des chiffres et des
lettres à mai et si on espace de six
semaines se protéger pendant 18 mois
d'accord voilà on pense que çà çà çà
c'est un effet sur la la la la longueur
de la période de protection
le fait de raccourcir l'espacement entre
les doses temps qu'on les faut quand
même laissé on va dire est le premier
vaccin tente de faire son effet de mai
l'organisme de mettre en place une
barrière voilà c'est mon ralliement
avant de faire la deuxième dose pour ktm
dosage dix comme un rappel qui va
réactiver et renforcer tous ses défenses
là on pense c'est de l'ordre de 3 à 4
semaines
mais voilà sont fait vacciner après cinq
semaines on a pas de risque que le
vaccin soit moins efficace on a fait un
petit deal soit un prix fixe un peu
moins longtemps
alors après pour je pense encore une
fois pour des jeunes adultes en bonne
santé je pense pas que là que l'enjeu
soit énorme l'enjeu va plus se poser
pour des personnes fragiles âgées
fragiles qui ont un système unitaire
moins performants et d'ailleurs pour qui
on envisage déjà une troisième dose que
c'était le premier thaksin et puis que
cet automne en a on a la crainte de
nouvelles vagues on se dit que peut-être
il faudra une dose de rappel pour pour
réactiver leur système immunitaire
à ma connaissance la question n'est pas
tranchée mais les autorités sanitaires
se prépare déjà ce scénario parce qu'il
faut l'anticiper
cela veut dire qu'il faudrait conserver
toute la structure de centre vaccinaux
qu'on amis et qu'on a mis en place qu'à
une certaine inertie qui a eu du mal à
apprendre à monter en puissance qui
maintenant fonctionne quand même fin
on peut le dire bien c'est un bon réseau
qui marche bien voilà il
si on doit en vacciner 20 30 millions de
personnes cet automne il faut absolument
la la maintenir et maintenir
voilà moi je vous dis à votre personnel
par exemple moi j'ai un peu avant c'est
ma deuxième dose pour des raisons de
convenance personnelle
est ce que j'avais un programme un
calendrier très chargé de travail et que
j'avais peur que le visionnaire la
deuxième dose qui peut avoir des petits
effets secondaires une fièvre etc avons
mieux savoir qu'on peut avoir une
journée on a un peu patraque
je préférerais que ça arrive un moment
où vous étiez maintenant gérer les
quidams mesure de le gérer encore une
fois je pensais pas très grave on peut
le choisir une manière de le décaler 12
semaines plus tard il faut savoir que
son certificat vaccinale n'est valide
que deux semaines après la deuxième dose
ou que si vous avez des voyages de prévu
et sait se faire que dans ses labs
attendent de moi s'est il faut la voilà
il faut il faut première dose deuxième
dose plus de semaine d'accord que ça
prend un peu de temps
ça prend un peu de temps qu'est ce que
vous répondez à cet internaute franck
weil de santé qui a supprimé son message
mais en fait ils s'interrogeaient est-ce
que je vais les retrouver
et
tout tout tout tout tout et bien non il
a supprimé son message mais c'était
plutôt intéressant et parlé d' immunité
collective il estimé lui que l'immunité
collective était autrement plus efficace
qu'une vaccination collective l'immunité
que la vexation collective a pour but
d'atteindre une immunité collective donc
artificiel
si je comprends ce qu'il voulait dire
c'est que alors l'immunité collective
selon lui c'était d'avoir chopé le virus
est d'en avoir été malade et d'être
protégées naturellement sans être passé
par une vaccination
oui alors ça on va dire que c'est ça si
on fait ça en fait on avait estimé le
nombre de morts si on laisse le virus
courir etc
les ravages c'était jour à quatre cent
mille morts en quatre ans 600 1000 morts
en france beaucoup essentiellement des
personnes âgées c'était l'argument de
certaines personnes
voilà donc déjà bon première jeu
j'imagine mal ses pouvoirs publics dire
voilà on a cinq cent mille morts c'est
acceptable
d'autre part ça veut dire saturation des
hôpitaux rue et ça veut dire que plein
de gens qui vont avoir des pathologies
tout à fait donc on peut guérir et tous
vont mourir on a parlé des thromboses où
les thromboses typiquement c'est très
très fréquents ça se soigne bien à
l'hôpital c'est les hôpitaux sont
débordés qu'on peut plus rien qu'on les
thromboses ben voilà ils vont mourir de
thrombose sans même avoir eu locaux
vides il ya tout cet effet en cascade
bien que cette question que vous abordez
la sueur sur la problématique de des
hôpitaux submergés par des vagues de
passions qu'on peut pas qu'on peut pas
soigner ça fait l'objet de nombreux
débats ou des rubis et ça pourrait
devenir de nouveau un un sujet c'est
s'élancer le cener de la guerre fin
gérant le ont leur l'oublié un peu parce
que finalement on a réussi à l'éviter
à chaque fois par des mesures drastiques
de confinement mais ç'a toujours été
l'enjeu le l'enjeu premier c'était ne
pas saturer les hôpitaux et donc du coup
bas with la question tout à fait se
reposer
cet été je ne sais pas peut-être cet été
le redémarrage épidémie peut être
important cet été est-ce qu'on pourrait
arriver à la situation des hôpitaux à
fin juillet je pense pas mais encore une
fois on a l'exemple de cet hiver on
attendu le dernier moment en espérant
que ça passe ça n'est pas passé s'est
pas passé on a dû confiner longtemps
alors que ça n'allait confiné au coeur
de l'hiver 3 semaines un confinement
violente est de même de même deux trois
semaines en fermant les écoles en
fermant tout on aurait prononcé
tranquille jusqu'à l'été là la nouvelle
donne c'est quand même la vaccination a
comme un prix de la place par rapport à
l'hiver dernier la vague laisse un vide
à place mais pas du tout c'est
finalement donc on est on reste sur un
terrain de jeu pour le vieux aussi
extrêmement important l'autre l'autre
point c'est que la l'immunité conférée
par le vaccin semble plus solide que
l'immunité naturelle conférée par un
primo infection notamment les primo
infection on peut penser aux variants
originel de onecare il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui ont pu contracter le virus
la première année il semblerait que
voilà le risque de réinfection avec le
variant d'indiens soit pas du tout
négligeable
c'est naturel en plus elle est assez
ancienne il faut la rusty mulet par une
injection
donc je pense que pour toutes ces
raisons non se compter sur les mines
étaient naturels en se passant du vaccin
serait faire un grave contresens
et un grand danger de santé publique et
un grand danger pour notre liberté tout
simplement parce que ya chez les
personnes qui sont réfractaires au
vaccin pour des raisons qui leur
appartiennent certaines compréhensible
parfois d'autres moins mais aujourd'hui
le vaccin c'est aussi notre liberté
c'est la possibilité de retourner à une
vie normale collectivement et c'est un
effort collectif à produire donc la
vaccination le vaccin présente comme
n'importe quel produit pharmaceutique et
secondaire des effets secondaires des
risques dans le gard d'astrazeneca
ils sont très largement inférieur aux
bénéfices qu'on peut en attendre pour
les personnes âgées et pour les
personnes plus jeunes si on prend en
compte cette dimension de liberté
retrouvée de je pense que les bénéfices
ont aussi le plus important à titre
individuel parfois ils le sont ils
peuvent sembler lettres - par le vaccin
grâce decca
le risque quand on a 30 ans de mourir du
coc vide ou de mourir d'une thrombose
veineuse évoque ses astra zeneca et
mettons comparable je pense qu'il est
quand même plus faible avec son bose
mais bon peu importe on rentre pas dans
ce débat là oui il m'est donc il est
comparé à mai le gain de liberté qu'on
en se faisant vacciner est largement
supérieure moi à titre personnel si
j'avais eu accès aux vaccins astrazeneca
vous l'auriez près j'aurais pris
immédiatement et encore aujourd'hui je
me ferai vacciner avec lui sans hésiter
je salue les nombreux internautes qui
nous ont rejoints sur le chat du figaro
le roux tuer ou kriss kross toujours
fidèle au chat du figaro pour commenter
et poser des questions en direct
je salue également chantal la goutte qui
nous qui nous fait une remarque fort
pertinente effectivement parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est toujours un peu
évacuer rapidement elle nous dit bonjour
à tous et à toutes j'aimerais que l'on
respecte les personnes âgées qui sont
décédés oui certes ce sont des personnes
âgées qui sont décédés mais pâques le
point d'exclamation effectivement on a
souvent mis en avant des chiffres sur
les décès en particulier en oubliant que
derrière il y avait des humains des
familles en particulier et sur les
personnes âgées elles ont toujours été
souvent relayé au second plan
parce que âgées et que donc c'était
peut-être moins importants que des
personnes jeunes c'est un phénomène je
pense qu'il est cac qui applique ans je
paye il eut un moment une prise de
conscience collective qui refuse qu'on
savait dès le départ
enfin en tout cas qu'on voit plus les
rôles figaro je peux vous le retrouvez
très très tôt sur la prépondérance des
cas graves chez les personnes âgées et
des morts chez les personnes de plus en
plus âgés pour autant c'est l'honneur
d'une société de défendre c'est plus
fragilisées personnes âgées les anciens
eysines les anciens et puis ces anciens
sont des grands parents sont des gens
qui avaient parfois dix quinze ans de de
vie en bonne santé devant elle et qui
ont été fauchés par le cos vide il ya
des personnes de moins de 30 ans qui
sont décédées aux simpson a beaucoup
moins
et puis les personnes 65 ans est ce
qu'aujourd'hui dans un pays comme la
france avoir soin de cinq ans et être
une personne âgée ou en tout cas qui
n'est plus bon à rien oui voilà qui
n'est plus ce n'est plus utile à satiété
tout jeu j'en suis pas du tout convaincu
et c'est une très bonne remarque cdc des
personnes qui chaque matin à la retraite
mais qui sont aussi des grands parents
qui sont des personnes qui ont oeuvré
pour le site est leur vie qu'ils ont le
droit de vivre
voilà qui ont le droit de vivre en bonne
santé heureux et sans la crainte d'un
virus qui circule à la fatigue et une
époque où certaines personnes voulaient
qu on confine les personnes âgées chez
elles
voilà ça m'a toujours semblé
injuste oui aberrant après aujourd'hui
maintenant on a des armes pour protéger
ces personnes là elles ont des armes
pour se protéger il faut qu'ils en
profitent
je parie dax astrazeneca voilà ses
besoins de cinq ans vous êtes pas encore
vaccinés bah allez vous faire vacciner
avec ses astra zeneca fait le soulève
pas pour vous faites devant vos
petits-enfants
si vous n'êtes pas pour autant fait le
pur pour la communauté pour vos amis que
vous aimez que vous voyez vous avez
envie de voir
voilà c'est un geste moi qui me paraît
tellement simple après tout ce qu'on a
vécu en plus face à ce virus
voilà autant mon les gens veulent passer
quiconque la grippe parce qu'ils ont ils
comprennent pas alors que le bon le
bénéfice très importants etc
mais je comprends que ce soit peut-être
un peu moins visible évident qu'on
puisse plus dire qu'ils sont là pour le
coup est vide on a quand même tous vécu
la même chose même confinement le même
désastre économique
on a cette arme incroyable inespéré je
le rappelle c'est inespéré d'avoir un
vaccin efficace à 90% avec très peu
d'effets secondaires aussitôt dans
l'épidémie est disponible par millions
de doses c'est inespéré
cette arme là on aurait aimé rêver
l'avoir bien sûr absolument
mais justement par rapport à cette
efficacité la rapidité aussi avec
laquelle le vaccin a été a été produit
ou développer et créer et bien pour
certains ça crée des inquiétudes vous en
parliez des gens qui hésitent à se faire
vacciner qui ne veulent pas se faire
vacciner les aptitudes sont nombreuses
beaucoup d'idées reçues circulent
tristan vais sur les vaccins j'aimerais
qu'on revienne justement sur
quelques-unes d'entre elles de ses idées
reçues ben justement le développement
des vaccins a été bâclée on ne peut pas
leur faire confiance
qu'est-ce qu'on répond à ceux qui
mettent en doute l'efficacité parce que
justement l'élaboration de ces vaccins
étaient bien trop courte et qu'en
général ça prend 10 maintenant avant
d'arriver à tenir un résultat
en fait elle le cisa prend autant de
temps pour obtiendrez des vaccins c'est
qu'il ya besoin de moyens financiers
considérables
alors là il ya des milliards et des
milliards qui ont été mis sur la table
notamment par le gouvernement américain
par deux êtres homme qui a dès le début
au vaccin peut lui peut mettre ça à son
crédit ça a considérablement aidé le
développement de ces vaccins qui ensuite
ont fait l'objet d'essais cliniques tout
à fait traditionnelle et pour lesquels
les résultats ont été spectaculaires
dans tous les sens maintenant on a
vacciné
quand même des milliards de personnes
valeur vaccin injecté 3 milliards de
doses donc peut-être un milliard n y eut
deux milliards de personnes
s'il y avait quelque chose et on
attendait dans des circonstances je le
rappelle de pharmacovigilance inédite le
l'effet secondaire qu'on a vu sur le
servent à sion en temps réel sur la home
conséquent d'individus qui permet
d'avoir des remontées trappier
exactement et pino mais ce n'est qu'une
vigilance particulièrement élevé des
autorités parce que tous les pays le
font en même temps vacciner en même
temps de manière massive ce qu'on a vu
sur le vaccin d'astrazeneca
c'est à dire le le l'identification de
thrombose veineuse cérébrale rarissime
un c'est qu'on n'a pu confirmer que
c'était bien lié au vaccin
en dépit du fait que c'était un cas sur
jules combien 600000 de quelques
millions une chance sur un million ou
gens sont 6 millions de de développer à
une thrombose cérébrale ce qui je
rappelle qu'à un cas de thrombose pour
une femme qui aurait pu servir au mieux
après enfin c'est à 104 me pour une
vaste remise pour la pilule fabre on est
on est dans des ordres de grandeurs
trois noms différents mais peu importe
ça fait ça fait très peur on arrive à
détecter des signes de pharmacovigilance
extrêmement ténue donc si les vaccins
rn12 viser quelque chose d'un peu grave
on se serait rendu compte après quand
tout fonctionne le recul qu'est-ce que
ça aura comme conséquence dans dix ans
dans 20 ans malheureusement pas le
savoir comme ça ça marche pas comme ça
il n'y a aucune raison de le penser ce
que on vaccine des enfants depuis des
années daniel système différent mais les
principes sont un peu toujours les mêmes
l'activation du système immunitaire etc
on sait les maladies immuno logique que
ça peut donner qui sont extrêmement
faibles que ça peut déclencher mais dont
on pense qu'elles ce thriller peut-être
déclenchez elle-même ça peut juste être
le facteur déclencheur n'en est pas
encore enfin c'est parce qu'ils sont
complètement comprise
en tout cas vous suscité la colère d'un
certain nombre d'internautes en
particulier kriss kross qui est infidèle
1 s'échappe du figaro puisque il
s'exclame pas content que le figaro a
des parts chez pfizer au modern war
effectivement les interroge parce que
vous défendez les vaccins effectivement
de pfizer ou modern à même de der
straeten etc ah non le figaro n'a pas de
parent dans ces entreprises
pas du tout on essaye d'être le plus les
vaccins les vaccins quel qu'il soit les
maladies gérant dont on a éradiqué des
maladies en tire grâce aux vaccins on
l'oubli on vit dans une société on est
très protégée par les vaccins et du cou
paradoxalement on a oublié qu'on avait
ce bouclier transparent au dessus de
nous qui nous protégeait de tas de
maladies grâce à la vaccination
obligatoire des enfants
faut-il le rappeler voilà je sais pas
la variole on est taxé vous n'avez rien
mes moyens on a permis d' éradiquer la
variole
il ya le toutes les maladies rubéole
au rayon alors certains vont vous
opposez qu'effectivement ça ce sont des
peut-être des vaccins qui sont élaborés
à partir d'une méthode à l'ancienne on
va dire un peu sur le modèle de base et
à quel moment lorsque l'on cerne à est
raide parmi les les inquiétudes 1 et
parmi les les idées reçues qui circulent
un certain disent les vaccins arn repose
sur une technologie totalement nouvelle
qui n'avait pas encore été testé chez
l'humain et donc qu'ils estiment qu'il
ya un danger une dangerosité qui est
avéré peut-être selon eux en tout cas
chaire moyen ou long terme il n'y a pas
deux il ya aucune dangerosité avérée ça
repose sur rien les craintes on plaide
entendre elle repose sur aucun fondement
scientifique à cette heure voilà après
refusé de faire vacciner quand on est
jeune et en bonne santé
c'est prendre la responsabilité de la
mort de personnes âgées de personnes
plus âgées
et pas que voilà après chacun fait en
son âme et conscience à moi je trouve
que c'est irresponsable et canton tous
ces gens le noyau dur des gens qui sont
pas sélectionnés ils sont bien contents
que 90% des gens soient vaccinés mettre
fin à l'épidémie trouve toujours des
excuses pour dire que voilà il avait
bien dit kevin estaminet de même qu'ils
sont pas vaccinés ils ont bénéficié de
l'effort collectif de tous les autres
tant mieux pour eux je trouve pas que ce
soit quelque chose de très honorables
sur la rn messager
certains prétendent qu'il modifie le
code de génétique des personnes qui
reçoivent la dose de vaccin non pas du
tout ça fonctionne pas comme ça le
vaccin arn en fait simple c'est un peu
compliqué mais en gros le ce qui est
contenu dans le noyau des cellules c'est
de l'adn
et cet adn est transformé en arn dans
les cellules ensuite et relargués dans
la cellule où les brins d arn vont être
transformés en protéines et ses
protéines en cédant cependant encore et
donc voilà sont soit des hormones des
c'est ça qui sont pour constant de
nouvelles cellules bref c'est toute
cette arène apparaître de produire
toutes les briques indispensable à ce
qu'un corps fonctionne et puis ce évolué
et du coup c'est les vaccins et rennes
vont 10 points en fait faire en sorte
que de la rn rentrer dans la cellule
sans arrêt dans le noyau pour être
transformés en protéines spy qui vont
ensuite sa tâche et se mettra surface de
certaines cellules pour déclencher une
action militaire faire comme si c'était
des petits virus contre lesquels voilà
ce qui explique la la douleur un peu au
point de au point d'injection il se
passe quelque chose ici le corps
commence à réagir à ça va s'y attaquer
le site et militaires s'emballe ça peut
expliquer les effets secondaires comme
la fièvre etc
vous avez envie d'avoir la grippe oui
c'est un peu ce qui se passe le corps
est en train d'essayer de combattre ce
qu'ils pensent être un ennemi et ensuite
la réaction s'arrête et ensuite on si on
est si le virus arrive on va réagir
instinctivement il n'y a pas de raison a
priori que ce que cet arn et le moindre
effet ils se dégradent ensuite très
rapidement dans le corps il peut pas se
répliquer voilà il ya des vaccins
à vecteur à vecteur viral qui finalement
vont amener de l'adn ont noué des
cellules pour induire la production des
reines dans les cellules qui est du coup
les plus proches on va dire de quelque
chose qui pourrait modifier l'adn et
personne personne ni à vue
vu de mal s'est passé beaucoup de
beaucoup de mes connaissances en fait de
ces processus qui fait peur aux gens
dans les dents lisant vous avez aussi
également et on l'a vu souvent sous
forme de vidéos de témoignages sur les
réseaux sociaux en particulier que les
vaccins rendent magnétique
non ça c'est qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
leur répondre je sais pas c'est
désarmant
non nous n'avons pas magnétique n'ayant
pas magnétique on le disait tout à
l'heure on l'abordé avec le royaume uni
où des personnes s'interrogent toujours
sur l'efficacité des vaccins en mettant
en avant le fait qu'au royaume uni la
propagation du virus allait elle a
redémarré il ya une reprise de
l'épidémie est pour eux le vaccin du
coup et la vaccination ne fonctionne pas
puisque il ya un redémarrage est donc la
couverture vaccinale ne sert à rien
qu'est ce que vous pouvez répondre de
nouveau à ceux qui affirment que une
couverture vaccinale ne sert à rien
puisque évidemment dans les pays où on
vacciner mais finalement l'épidémie le
problème s'il faut regarder ce qu'on
s'entende pas le campagne de vaccination
et en grande bretagne ce choix donc je
rappelais au début de de dépasser les
doses mais qu'on ait eu beaucoup
beaucoup de gens vaccinés avec une dose
et ce variant qui se révèle plus
efficace qui se révèle peu arrêté par
une seule dose de vaccin qui a besoin
vraiment une protection complète donc
c'est un c'est pas de chance ou encore
une femme en bretagne l'épidémie a bien
redémarré mais les paysans ne sont pas
repartis à la hausse
leleu le vaccin limitent la transmission
mais ne ne l'empêchent pas complètement
mais il limite très très drastiquement
les raisons et les formes graves mais
aggrave donc aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut
dire de la grande bretagne c'est qu'en
dépit d'un redémarrage assez important
d'épidémie
il n'y a pas eu l'emballement des
hôpitaux ce qui est plutôt rassurant
si c'est le cas du coup quelque part on
sera le sauver on pourra vivre avec le
virus si on peut si les gens sont
contaminés qui n'ont pas de forme grave
à l'hôpital qui meurt peu y aura plus
lieu de saint cricq s'inquiéter outre
mesure après sera titre individuel qu'il
était
s'il sera comme la grille pourquoi voilà
quand quand la grippe circulent les
hivers vaut mieux faire attention quoi
mais pour les personnes les plus
fragiles
ce sera pas un motif on va dire de
confinement vainement généralisée du
pays donc si ça se poursuit comme ça en
angleterre
très bien mais le monstre concerne à la
france de mener vite là dessus ce que
montrent les modèles c'est que donc
c'est un bon signal avec un cinq pièces
mais on sait que même avec les vaccins
efficaces l'épidémie redémarre beaucoup
plus et c'est ça qui est inquiétant en
break sa dynamique ça que les amis comme
ça semble s'emballer
si le niveau très haut en dépit de la
protection vaccinale on va remplir les
hôpitaux d'accord et c'est ce qui
pourrait se passer chez lipp réponse est
non chez nous aussi alors on est comme
ça très précoce ça paraît un peu de
science fiction oui mais pour avoir vécu
des chats trois vagues précédentes avoir
dit à peu près la même chose à chaque
vague et ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que à la rentrée si personne n'y prête
garde si les gens ne font pas attention
lorsqu'elle a rentré le redémarrage de
leur et des majors a déjà été assez
important pour que les gens fassent un
peu à temps et donc on risque quoi des
restrictions c'est certain la section
forme je pense que des coups fumants de
nouveaux sera impactée au point de
devoir fermer des écoles
c'est possible si ça tournait travailler
à la maison il ya un débat il y aura un
débat qui va devoir avoir lieu sur la
vaccination des enfants
qu'il a pour le coup est plus délicate
alors qu on pèse le poids le conduit à
des effets secondaires
les enfants ont tellement peu de risque
de formes graves et comme il ya quelques
effets secondaires
on va dire ddd un peu un peu délicat on
va certaines réticences pour l'instant à
a autorisé avec cinq sont des vents des
plus jeunes
pour l'instant c'est que les adolescents
je le rappelle on va voir s'il faut
actionner les plus jeunes aussi
ils constituent des vecteurs importants
des maladies et donc si l'ouverture des
écoles en septembre déclenché un une
recrudescence de l'épidémie qu'il n'y a
pas ces personnes vaccinées et cessera d
des questions à se poser c'est le cv
risque après le on sait que le virus
préfère le l'hiver là on le voit il ya
un redémarrage afrique du sud tient en
fin d'hiver austral c'est quelque chose
qu'on a bien documenté qui est assez
classique pour les infections
respiratoires qui pas surprenant donc
voilà on si l'épidémie redémarre même à
la faveur de l'été il ya de quoi
craindre pour cet automne
un redémarrage important et encore une
fois on n'a pas de recette miracle virus
ne s'arrête pas de lui même est ce que
ça veut dire qu'il faut imposer en
définitive parce que la question se pose
en ce moment et la vaccination
collective obligatoire pas simplement
pour les personnels soignants mais pour
l'ensemble de la population
je suis ni favorable ni défavorable
je pense que c'est un débat qui mérite
c'est un débat qui mérite d'être
considérée pour dire je vois pas de de
frein absolue avec ses actions
obligatoire geler les vaccins allaient
des enfants l'accès aux habitants pour
les enfants iront ce vaccin je je je
pense que c'est simplement délicat dans
la mesure tant qu'on n'aura pas de doses
pour vacciner tout le monde
il me paraît difficile conceptuellement
d'obliger les gens à se vacciner sans
les avoir la capacité à faire deux à le
faire et même si on sait qu'on peut pas
le faire du jour au lendemain je je
comprend la réticence des autorités à
adopter cette mesure aujourd'hui si on
se retrouve dans un contexte on a
beaucoup de doses disponibles et
beaucoup de gens à vacciner
je pense que la question aura tout son
sens et je pense qu'il est important
qu'on mène le débat en amont
donc pour moi le débat avoir ce débat là
aujourd'hui et récents je pense pas
qu'il faille le trancher dès maintenant
mais je pensais bien d'ouvrir que les
gens soient conscients que c'est une
possibilité
c'est envisagé
est ce que ça peut convaincre les
indécis le devoir ce débat là je sais
pas mais je pense qu'il faut que les
gens prennent conscience que c'est notre
seule solution
or confinement quoi en fait il y en a
pas mille solutions coin on a les gestes
barrière mais que geste barrière qui dit
ça veut dire fermeture des restaurants
par exemple je pense à tous les
restaurateurs qui ont pas envie d'être
refermées et je les comprends mais
tellement pour les discothèques qui
s'apprête à rouvrir le discothèques etc
il ya des diagrammes des activités qui
sont difficilement compatibles avec un
respect strict des gestes barrières et
c'est bien naturel donc du coup que pour
ses activités là la seule solution qui
reste c'est le vaccin voilà je joue du
coup voilà bon s'il faut pas se faire d
xamax nice qu'il faudra rendre certaines
activités dépendantes d'un certificat
élargi justifiera qu'on a été vaccinée
voilà très largement non pas pour encore
une fois je pense que l'idée est patent
de restreindre ses activités là aux gens
vaccinez c'est pas d'exclure et oui ils
veulent pas se vacciner de ses activités
là c'est de les motiver à se faire
vacciner c'est qu'elle a une incitation
à le faire je sais que c'est là la
différence par être subtil mais ça passe
comme vous l'avez dit par une pédagogie
impénitente effet dégagé d'importantes
informations sur et par un nombre de
doses disponibles suffisamment également
sur le cas à la logistique exactement
aujourd'hui interdire l'accès
des restaurants personnes non vaccinées
alors même que tous ne veut pas se faire
vacciner
je trouverais ça très injuste mais rien
que je suis vacciné je parle pas des
personnes mais je trouve ça super
injuste tristan va notre notre démission
touche à sa fin on va finir avec une
question de kriss kross effectivement
qui est intéressante quid des
traitements on parle beaucoup de
vaccination qu'en est-il de traitement
sur des gens malades
alors pour l'instant les traitements on
n'a malheureusement pas grand chose il
ya lui s'interroge pourquoi on ne parle
jamais des traitements je pense que
c'est pas tout à fait correct on ne sait
pas qu'on parle jamais des traitements
c'est quand il y en ait eu beaucoup
beaucoup de recherches et très peu de
succès encore une fois le livecd vaccin
c'est même prix c'est quand même une des
grandes surprises et est pas la recette
d'un seul vaccin mais de plusieurs et
c'est pas bon ça notre débat sur les
traitements
le problème et c'est le cas pour tous
les virus on ne dispose pas d'anti
viraux très efficace on a fini par avoir
des thérapies pour contenir le virus
pour le sida mais qui je rappe fait le
ravalement passer des rétrovirus et
l'iran crois qu'il est très différent
mais on dispose de traitements qui
permet de maintenir les personnes avec
une charge virale très basse au point de
ne même plus être contagieux ce qui est
génial ça a mis 30 ans et avec des
efforts de recherche considérable
la loco vie de un an et demi donc dans
la premier temps on a fait ce qu'on peut
dire qu'on a regardé tout ce qu'on avait
à disposition dans la pharmacopée s'est
dit on va regarder une vie trop ça
marche ça marchait pour c'est un produit
dont hydroxy chloroquine mais pas que et
plein d'autres et ensuite on est passé à
l'être humain
enfin à l'animal que l'être humain
souvent directement à l'être humain dès
qu'ils tendaient le caractère d'urgence
et ça n'a jamais marché la seule chose
qui a un peu marcher c'est un
des corticostéroïdes pour limiter
l'inflammation et la rentrée des
symptômes si on n'est pas du tout virus
il ya des traitements de prise en charge
puis il ya l oxygène à haut débit eu de
grands pour rien la prise en charge
qu'on permet de limiter la mortalité
limiter la gravité est tellement moins
lourd en particulier sur la prise en
charge les insuffisances respiratoires -
d'éviter l'intubation et en mettant
d'occident thérapie à haut débit il ya
eu des lieux en progrès y a encore
récemment des associations qui ans qui
ont montré des choses intéressantes pour
pour réduire la durée d'hospitalisation
machin mais ça ne ça ne s'en prend pas
aux virus et pas des antiviraux c'est
pas quelque chose vous prenez vous êtes
malade
voilà belem meilleur guérit pas c'était
un village
ça soulage le but est d'accompagner le
d'éviter la non pas les noms ne traite
pas le problème
ça traite pas l'origine du problème
c'est un virus à dubaï virus on commence
à arriver dans une phase où deux
premières molécules mises au point
spécifiquement contre le virus arrive en
essais cliniques mais les essais
cliniques c'est long ça prend un peu de
temps
nokia fait le temps de 10 années ces
molécules de faire des essais
préliminaires maintenant passer décès il
faut une perspective optimiste dans
l'état actuel des recherches de la
recherche ya alors c'est ça va pas
plaire la crise sociale parce que j'ai
des actions il ya un traitement pro il
ya fayza une molécule qui sont
prometteuses
c'est pas moi qui livre moi j'en pense
que rien mais bon on n'a pas l'aval de
spécialistes qui ont l'air assez
enthousiasmés par les promesses mais
avec beaucoup de prudence parce qu'on
sait qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de cas où ça ne marche pas
vraiment et l'autre l'autre chose c'est
que quand on a un vaccin efficace
voilà c'est plus difficile de de
financer un traitement ou de ou même de
d'en voir l'intérêt parce qu'on se
disait de se vacciner on gère pas les
amis donc le c'est bien d'avoir un
complément
surtout si le virus atténué les effets
si le vaccin pardon atténuer les effets
du virus et que les hospitalisations
sont moindres du coup la recherche pour
un traitement semble carbure moins que
celle pour le pour le vaccin voilà après
bon son comme il ya beaucoup bouyahia
comme beaucoup de pays dans le monde que
les on est loin d'être tous vaccinés cas
la crainte de ces nouveaux variants et
que peut-être un traitement pour le
reste efficace contre invariants alors
même qu'il échappe à l'immunité conférée
par un pas que ça je n'y a pas de ça
reste tout à fait intéressant et
d'actualité trouver un traitement et les
décès sont toujours en cours si on en
parle moins c'est parce que l'enjeu de
ces derniers mois ça a beaucoup été la
vaccination le contenir l'épidémie
et dans ce contexte là on savait
avait-on et les temps les temps
nécessaire qu'on n'était pas dans là
dedans dans la temporalité ou un
traitement ailes et nous permettre d'en
venir à bout il ya eu l'espoir d'aider
monoclonaux qui fonctionne pour
certaines personnes dans certains cas
particuliers mais qui sont est très bon
très très lourd saluera mettre en oeuvre
étrangère probablement très cher mais
c'est encore une fois j'en avais un
traitement
ça me fait chier swing chaque personnage
et avec lui un fils vu le fric ou de dix
mille euros en le ferai parce que je
pense que le coût final pour la société
serait beaucoup moins important que
celui des confinement successifs et
c'est donc c'est le coût d'un faux
problème
le coup est un faux problème le vrai
problème c'est que ces traitements de
l'intraveineuse qui essaie d'aller à
l'hôpital qui décide donc d'hospitaliser
des gens pendant des semaines
enfin pendant une semaine par exemple en
est un traitement dans le but est de les
empêcher d'aller à l'hôpital
ce qui n'a pas vraiment de sens
finalement on va absorber dix fois plus
de personnes à l'hopital pour en
empêcher pour les empêcher d'y rentrer
on le le le on se retrouve pas pour
certaines personnes qui sont extrêmement
à risque
ça devient très intéressant ça une
combinaison de monoclonaux mais c'est
pas vrai ce n'est pas la panacée quoi
c'est pas c'est pas la pilule c'est pas
le doliprane comprend en tout cas pas
encore passé tamoil pardon merci
beaucoup
tristan valentin lisandro et chef
adjoint du service sciences et médecine
au figaro d'avoir répondu aux
internautes et à nos questions et
d'avoir fourni une expertise hyper
intéressante et de qualité j'espère que
ça vous a aidé vous qui nous suivait en
direct en ce moment sur figaro live et
youtube avant vos vacances ou pendant
vos vacances et puis en prévision de
cette rentrée qu'on annonce un peu
chaotique
au vu des chiffres qui paraissent ces
derniers jours merci encore de nous
avoir suivi et à très vite et à très
bientôt sur figaro life